welcome to another edition of a beginner
breakdown i am your host Mike comer we
are broadcasting live from the VIP
boardroom up in the st. Louis chess club
this is where all the greats play at the
sink filled cup but not so great is our
old friend Harper Evan Smith all right
he he decided he's gonna plunk down his
his hundred bucks to play in the
Thanksgiving open try to win a thousand
and let's see how he did so he's got the
black pieces in this game against that
Eric Hoffner he's 2 and 0 he's feeling
great and all right so here we go so
Eric starts out efore Harper Emma Smith
goes for the Sicilian c5 and now his
opponent plays something of kind of
strange a 3 most of the time you'll see
you know the night out or the other
night out going into the Grand Prix
attack but a 3 very suspicious so so
hard forevers but just develops normal
and he plays Knight to c6 so if your
opponent played a 3 what do you think
has follow-up would be be four right ok
so high prevalence miss like oh my god
this is going to be like the easiest
game I've ever played i'm already up
upon and it's move a move for ok so he's
feeling really good right now so let's
see what white can do to the try and and
make this so it's a sound sacrifice so
he attacks the night night back now what
do you think White's going to play here
to get a really big center d for
excellent ok so that's his compensation
for the pawn okay he's got this really
nice pawn structure in the center let's
see if it's worth it alright so Harper
is just going to attack it with
d 5 so it's like okay I'll take it in
Queen takes okay so we don't really have
any good way to to attack the Queen here
so he's going to play night to a three
possibly preparing Bishop to c4 but
after e6 why is Bishop to c4 not a good
move in this position yeah because you
just hang upon Queen takes g2 so we
don't want to be hanging hanging puns
okay so he's just going to go for it
night to be five so so he's threatening
what's called the family fork right the
Queen the King and the rook the whole
everybody right so Harper should should
realize this position and so now he's
got to stop it and the way he stops it
is his actual losing move Bishop to d6
it looks like an innocent move right I'm
stopping night to c7 check which would
lose everything much better is just
retreating the Queen for it just so
everybody knows okay so white has a
crusher in this position so Bishop to c4
unfortunately I think the Queen where
would the Queen go hmm Bishop c4 looks
interesting because obviously it take
it's over oh but we have a nice check
and we're like who because it once he
blocks the check you know let's just say
for instance nighty too we can
I'm just going to go retrieve my bishop
all the way back and want any I don't
want that Bishop going anywhere and then
we'll be okay okay but good a good idea
but just not not good enough so besides
well what is the only piece or pawns
besides the rooks that are not protected
in this position so that's really what
you want to look for is when you're
looking for really good moves is look
for the undefended out pieces or ponds
so besides the rooks what's the only
other piece or pawn that isn't protected
in this position g7 right okay so how
can we attack it well the only way right
Queen g4 okay and it's a it's a stomper
okay it's a thumper so so Harper is like
oh I just move my night out see the
whole thing about Queen to g41 it
attacks the g pawn and now all of a
sudden your moves looking pretty good
right Bishop c4 because no check and now
Harper is like oh man if I could only
see Harper's face during this would have
been it would have been good so Harper
Evan Smith knows like oh man if I moved
my queen right he's going to play you
know night takes d6 check and it's all
falling apart for me so so he needs to
make a threat greater or equal to
Harper's obviously if you take the
bishop in it yep you get fort so King
moves Knight takes Queen okay so so he
needs to make a threat greater or equal
so he tries the move h
five so Eric's like I don't care Bishop
takes pawn takes right and now we got
the check okay so now we're up a piece
currently king of eight and he can just
consolidate now Bishop takes Knight
takes Knight takes rook takes and all of
a sudden we have one two three four
pieces and Harper only has three and so
nighty too and so now Harper tries a
little trick here play king e8 so then
on the next move he can castle does
anybody believe me but Eric was Eric
Eric thought it was true because he
plays Bishop to a three to prevent the
castling so Harper's like enough of all
that mumbo jumbo I'm going to bring my
rook out like this now like we've all
had kids classes before right isn't that
the number one thing you ever learned in
kids classes never bring your book out
like this because only bad things can
happen when when this happens so so okay
so now the rook is off the back row so
it's more easily attacked so here he
goes so he moves his rook to be five and
now look look at a rook king rook what
can you tell me about just just the most
basic thing you can tell me about the
rook rook and the king they're all on
light squares excellent Mario okay so so
when when your pieces are on the same
colored squares right there more easily
fort or skewer door you know pinned okay
more easily to get a double attack right
so so Harper should have known he got he
was threatened to get triple family fork
earlier in the game and now how do we
threaten the family fork now
nitey for right and we're threatening
night to d6 and this is great this is
great so he plays Brooke the b3 and oh
no no no no no no no no so he plays king
the d7 thinking that okay my king
protects that square I'm not going to
get forked but boom he plops it right in
and there's nothing he can do Knight
takes King takes and it's looking pretty
bad for Harper so he protects his pawn
it was his night to a5 King attacks the
rook and hyper just throws in the towel
at this point he's like I can't take it
anymore I've got I've got nothing going
on so so Harper Evan Smith resigns so
Eric Hoffner took first place in the in
the under 2,000 section leaving Harper
tied for second so hurry / Evan Smith
did actually win 475 dollars but not the
kool g Harper Evan Smith is rated about
1930 because he was so close to expert
but but then he dropped like 50 points
ok so that's that's the under 2000 and
the Thanksgiving open now the real stuff
they open the feed a rated open section
all right you missed Harper Evan Smith's
the feet but just in time for Mario's
game back there all right so all right
so now Mario Roper who is present is
uh-oh even though it's just write a
thousand he decided hey in order to beat
the best I gotta beat the best so he's
like I'm playing the open he benefited
from a first round bye which was good
and now he's ready to take on wfmu
Louisa macedo alright and Mario's got
the black piece so we're looking at from
his our perspective alright so the wfm
starts efore mario goes with the classic
e5 ok Knight f3 attacks the pawn gotta
defend it so now Bishop to b5 so you
know in this position you know the
good-old-boy Lopez you know you know all
right maybe just continue normally
negative six but Mario's like I'm having
none of it yeah I'm not going to give
you a chance to even trade the bishop
for the night so he attacks the bishop
with his night so she takes it so so
what do you think ninety-nine percent of
the people would do in this position
yeah they were captured back right
instead Mario decides he wants to attack
the best shop thus giving the wfm a free
porn so she just takes it and Mario
takes back so the bishop retreats
attacking f7 here so Mario's like I'm
bringing my queen up so so now the queen
is attacking g2 but whenever you put
your queen out like this you've got to
know that it's on the same line so
discovered attacks can happen so so the
wfm is like no respect you know you got
a queen I'm just going to castle right
into it and so how can mario thread
checkmate in this position and I'm
saying it's a good move august bishop h
bishop h three trains checkmate but it's
not a good move because she's got this
Queen up three check and then she can
just take okay so so Mario saw so it's
like I'm not going to throw in checkmate
I'm going to thread your queen so he's
like no I'm going to attack you and now
Mario sees a check so he's got to play a
check and now what move is great for
white here yes d for double attack in
one it gets out of the check and to the
bishop is now attacking the Queen like
three of pieces three of Mario's pieces
are on pre right now it's pretty tough
to do Mario and you got to really work
at that ok so tomorrow is like I'm
taking it with check and she's like
jokes on you buddy and so Mario takes it
she takes it and now he retreats his
bishop so she attacks his poem Mary
decides I'm kind of really care i'll tak
your bishop so Bishop retreats tack it
again and now she's got two players on
you Mario right so I mean you might as
well just just get something forward you
know because when you castle Bishop
takes and now well there's two two moves
Mario could do in this position the
dreaded f6 move and f6 is not a good
move here because right because we can
remove the defender and then BOOM so
Mario's got to do the UH the
embarrassing rook h7 ok not a good
placement for that rook
alright so she takes a pawn Mario
attacks a Bishop Bishop retreats attacks
the other Bishop guess what Bishop
retreats get the night out a 4 alright
so now more eels like all right I'll
play some pins you know alright so so
what is a simple way for a white to get
out of this pin you could you could push
the pond but you know you just develop
your night and now the works are
protecting each other and you've
completed your development and up you're
looking pretty good here that's the no
Morea plays up five she takes so once
again Mario you know you got to take
this because when you take the rook she
gets like a free move here check you
know and now or you take with the King
you take with the King here ok I believe
it diseño pawn takes Knight takes rook
back check King attacks the rook another
check and see you night and now Mary
decides you know he just saw how you
know he lost the night so what's a funny
way to lose the bishop in this position
Bishop Jesus yeah and and now the
computer it took it took it a minute or
two to figure out that it was like mate
in eight here but before it could figure
out it was main eight the evaluation for
a Mario in this position was a negative
100 points so now look a very good Mario
so Mario must have known what they can
Peter was thinking and he threw in the
towel at this point so plus 100 doing
great oh wait cool so so memorial is not
dissuade he decides you know what I'm
going to take on the Grandmaster been
fine gold gold and mario has the white
pieces let's see if it works out any
better for Mario anybody taking a poll
at home not looking good for Mario okay
so okay so Mario I guess inspired by
Eric Hosmer decides to play a 3 but
let's see if he follows it up so all
right negative taxed upon so we got to
address the situation so Knight to c3
then plays 'if I've Bishop c4 attacking
up pivotal f7 here and now Ben knows a
trick I guess Knight takes pawn so if
Knight takes d5 even though the computer
won't let us play it it's so good
forking the pieces Mario could just take
right and then the Queen would take
eventually they probably really think
about it you know been fine goalies up
he doesn't want to brush and then we can
attack the Queen and then when the Queen
goes back you know you'll be doing so so
20 Queenie to all right so he takes so
he's like ok play that but I mean and
what advantages you get the bishop
rolling right away but but you know you
get the bishop develop so that's good of
course been fine goal is not going to
play f6 like the computers see they give
the computers recommend f6 in this
position so I want to put too much stock
in which way the pawn takes so obviously
been fine go plays d6 and not f6
and oh oh Mario's on the attack here
Knight to g5 did you really think this
was going to work and you played it
their way I mean what did you think he
was going to play when you play a Knight
to g5 were you just like I got him b5 so
you saw that but you just so obviously
so he plays d5 obviously and you just
you go for it huh Knight takes f7 all
right so obviously he's going to take it
so he gets the Queen check so he's got
two players Mario's got two players
attacking the deep on so so all right
you got the King out there but let's see
okay so you got to move the bishop now
so you retreat the bishop and keeping
the pin on obviously bent bangles going
to play a good move here c4 right
right so if when you play be four
obviously he's not going to play he's
not going to play um passat on you and
so b3 keeps the pressure on
yeah alright so so be four been fungal
obviously what's the consolidate Mario
is not going to let him Bishop d6
putting the bishop on the same diagonal
as the Queen Bishop attacks the Queen
Queen up Ben fangled doesn't have to
worry about his queen and king being on
the same line because Mario's bishop is
a forever out of the game now on a two
it's a Mario castles Bishop attacks the
Queen night and right there now Mario
plays h3 night g6 attacks the Queen and
here's the man himself then fine gold
right and so then we'll just consolidate
to a winning a game beef o we're just
trying to break it open here at four so
so how come in this position you just
didn't play up for right away if he
wasn't going to take it you know why
would you waste a move with f3 if you
weren't going to take that ok alright so
f4 so threatening the big a fork I'm
sure Ben is going to see it so he
retreats the King nor it keeps going
with this plan f6
alright so now mario has a passed pawn
here but let's see if it goes very far
so Bishop to h6 threatening Bishop g7 so
now Ben's got a night blocking the pawn
good g5 it's a bishop attacks the pawn I
don't see how Mario can defend it all
right now Ben doesn't even want the pond
doesn't sleep of RIP protects the bishop
and now Mario's got a threat though rook
takes a three so its bishops under
attack so he's got to move it alright so
be four so now Mario can go ahead with
this threat here Bishop attacks the rook
rook moves samaras got to take the pawn
ok so now Ben gets his pawn back attacks
the rook some mario taxed another pawn
king protects very easy stuff alright so
now Mario's doubled his rooks with the
intent of playing rook up here and then
getting the other book the checker let's
see if it works so Bishop to g3 check
notice it can't take it because of the
protected so now I Betty is going to
check them again
and so now band plays chuck so if he
takes it pawn takes check and then
you'll win the bishop and get a clean
all right so Mario sees it and place
King to see one Bishop back all right
Mario's murders got his look guys threat
going here all right so big check King
up what the play with the play with the
play so night to e4 what is black
threatening in this position all right
so well Mario saw the game so he knows
he now knows what so night to have to
check King moves but maybe we have even
better Knight to c3 yeah so Mario can't
resist taking and then checkmate
checkmate and been fine go finished tied
for third clear third 800 bucks all
thanks to this one point from Mario
brought them over the top okay we have
one more game
oh good I don't think I don't think you
owe me that much because I think you're
all right you know yet don't argue with
a man that's gonna pay you all right all
right I love it I love it all right I'll
take it I'll take it all right we'll go
back to the the under 2,000 we can't
resist will have bonus so this is a the
champion Eric Hoffner his first round
game against a Robert Beekman okay all
right so yeah so e 4 C 5 back to the ol
a3e 6b four so as we saw harp or he
couldn't resist you know getting two
pawns for one but now Roberts going to
try something else he's going to attack
the e pawn so and move it up night up c4
so I gotta move the night pawn takes
bishop so once again Eric Hoffner has a
achieved his dream position where he
gets the big center and in this case he
didn't actually even have to sacrifice a
pawn okay so who would play up for here
and just get all the ponds nope so eric
hoffman he loves Queen to g4 okay so so
as we saw in the other game you know the
wfm against Mario right when he played
Queen to uh you know g5 was it was the
case she's like I don't care I'll castle
right into it okay but yeah so so this
was that's the reason why you couldn't
do it in this position because she had
all those tricks like with the bishop
check and queen there Robert beekman's
got nothing you know so what's the only
move Robert Beekman can play here
g6 all right we'll play all right and
then we just take the rook Bishop takes
a night of three and now Knight takes e4
who thinks that is a good move yeah yeah
yeah yeah I just didn't see the best
shot yep sometimes it's tough all right
that's where I stop looking at it but
you know we can't resist them well maybe
we can resist and yep and Eric off their
wins about time moves later okay yeah
well thank you all for coming stick
around for Ben Feingold's class
mastering the middle game thank you very
much